banderas rojas de la liga nacional para
la democracia y tres dedos en alto
símbolos inequívocos de resistencia en
mianmar este lunes cientos de personas
marcharon por todo el país muchos de
ellos portando banderas del partido de
aung san suu kyi la líder de puesta por
la junta militar por primera vez desde
el golpe de estado del 1 de febrero
succi aparecía hoy para comparecer ante
un tribunal por los seis casos imputados
desde que la junta llegó al poder
sus abogados quisieron mandar un mensaje
con una onza en sus chiles dijo los
abogados que le dijeran a la gente que
ella se preocupó por el pueblo y algo
que dijo es que el partido surge del
pueblo y que donde esté el pueblo tiene
que estar necesariamente el partido el
partido puede existir allí donde esté el
pueblo también confirmaron que su chip
se encuentra en buen estado de salud
algo que quiso remarcar el líder de la
junta militar
aún san suu kyi está en buen estado de
salud ha estado en su casa todo este
tiempo y aparecerá en la corte en unos
días para ir a prisión
iván junto a ello declaró como falsas
las cifras de muertos que se reportan en
las protestas la asociación de
asistencia a presos políticos las cifran
al menos 818 y pone al no es justo que
algunos medios hayan exagerado sobre el
número de muertos diciendo que han sido
más de 700 este número no tiene
fundamento el número real de muertos
ronda los 300 la junta enfrenta ahora un
nuevo problema el aumento de los ataques
de las milicias populares creadas tras
el golpe su número ha crecido
paulatinamente y ya han causado decenas
de víctimas militares en todo el país